This episode is sponsored by Endel,
an app that creates personalized
soundscapes to help you focus,
relax and sleep.The first 100 people to click our
description link will get a one week free trial.
It’s probably hard to ignore the very obvious
green algae taking up most of your screen.
But for the moment, I want you to try. Look away
from the closterium and instead, shift your focus
to the area that surrounds it. At first, it may
not seem that interesting. It’s just a sea of
dark blue, interrupted only by tiny little dots.
But unlike the completely static closterium, those
tiny little dots are wiggling around in
frantic, uncoordinated directions like they’re
dancing to a million different soundtracks
played at once. There are organisms in the
world of the microcosmos that move in concerted,
directed ways, but this is definitely not that.
Now let’s focus on the closterium. Look towards
the tip of the algae, where there are round barium
crystals wiggling around in the same random
way that those particles we saw before were.
We’re going to see that type of motion over
and over again today because it’s all over the
microcosmos, found in and around many different
types of organisms. And this kind of random motion
may seem almost too trivial to discuss, leading
at best to an end where I mull over the way that
randomness seems to pop up everywhere like some
kind of unifying force that shapes our lives
through millions of tiny coincidences.
Except, well, there’s no point waiting
until the end to say all that because the
reason we want to talk about this weird,
wiggling motion is that this randomness really
does tie us together, not metaphorically, but
very, very literally and physically. This motion
that you see is a proof of something fundamental
not just to life, but to existence
itself. This movement is proof of atoms.
It’s easy to take the existence of atoms for
granted now, in the same way that it’s easy to
take the existence of microbes for granted. Once
you know about them and how they shape the world,
and you've been told about them since you
were a child,
it’s impossible to see the
world as existing without them.
But our knowledge of both is relatively recent,
even if it’s built on work that spans
millennia. And just as the microscope has been
essential to our understanding of microbes, it has
played an important role in understanding atoms.
Long before the existence of the
microscope though, there was an idea.
In the fifth century BCE, a Greek philosopher
named Democritus proposed that if you kept
breaking matter down further and further, you
would eventually reach something that could no
longer be broken down. That indivisible thing was
what he called atomos, which meant “uncuttable”.
Democritus’ theory was in opposition
to the ideas of Aristotle and Plato,
who believed that the world was composed of
four basic elements: earth, wind, air, and fire.
So what does Democritus have
to do with the tiny little
wobbles of the pigments inside this stentor?
For that, we have to flash forward to 1827.
This was an exciting time for anyone interested in
diving deep into what matter was made of. The end
of the 18th century had seen important advances
in our understanding of matter. And in 1803,
the scientist John Dalton drew upon these
ideas to propose that each chemical element
could be described by a particular atom.
The atom became a useful tool in developing new
theories about how our world is built, and 19th
century physicists used it to describe a theory of
gasses that assumed they were composed of many,
many tiny particles constantly moving around.
But these theories weren’t proof. If anything,
they raised more questions about how to think
about atoms. Should we think of atoms as
just some kind of mathematical metaphor,
or were they something real? And how could we
find proof of something as unseeable as an atom?
The answer, it would turn out, would come
thanks to a botanist named Robert Brown.
Brown wasn’t setting out to solve the
problem of atoms. It was the summer of 1827,
and he was trying to clear up some questions
he had about the tiny particles that burst
out of pollen grains like this one.
So he did what we’re doing right now:
he brought out his microscope, and looked at
some tiny things under it. While we didn’t have
those pollen particles on hand, we imagine that
what he saw was similar to these oil droplets,
which came from the body of a dying copepod.
He said simply, “While examining the form of
these particles immersed in water, I observed
many of them very evidently in motion,”.
Curious about this motion, Brown proceeded to do
a number of different experiments. He looked at
pollen from other plants and saw the same motion.
He looked at pollen from dead plants and saw the
same motion. He even moved on to inorganic
materials like rocks and saw the same motion.
In water, everything wiggled, even if it wasn’t
living. And that meant the motion wasn’t something
biological, it was rooted in something else.
These random movements are what we now call
Brownian motion. And in the decades that followed
his observation, physicists began to study it
in earnest so they could understand
the forces that shaped the movement.
For example, one scientist noted that smaller
particles exhibited faster motion compared to
larger ones, which you can see at play here
in the crystals lying within this amoeba,
with the larger crystals moving more
slowly compared to the smaller ones5.
But Brownian motion’s biggest impact would
come in 1905 when a scientist theorized
that the movement of the particles Brown
had watched was the result of other smaller
particles colliding into them. That scientist, you
probably know the name of, it was Albert Einstein.
And those smallerparticles were
water molecules, composed of
atoms that are packed with energy. And because of
that energy, the water molecules are constantly
moving and colliding. Sometimes they collide with
each other. And sometimes they collide into other
larger particles, which move erratically in
response. That is Brownian motion, a movement
shaped by atoms and their kinetic energy.
Einstein’s theories were built on equations,
but they provided a framework that would allow
experimentalists to use Brownian motion as a
way to see atoms and their energy at work. And
ultimately, it was the French scientist Jean
Perrin who put these theories to the test, using
a new microscope called the ultramicroscope to
not only study Brownian motion and confirm the
equations that drove Einstein’s theory, but also
to estimate the size of water molecules.
All of that discovery was made possible because a
botanist wanted to study some pollen.
Robert Brown was operating in a realm
that is familiar to us here on Journey to the
Microcosmos. He was exploring an invisible world.
But what he studied and what he described helped
us find an even more invisible world, one that was
still invisible under his microscope, except
that it was responsible for everything he was
seeing, not just the motions of the pollen grains,
but the pollen grains themselves and anything else
that was under his microscope, outside his
microscope, and even the microscope itself.
What he found in those wiggles—what you’re seeing
now in the same motion more than a century later,
is an invisible world that
built an entire universe.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Endel
for sponsoring this episode.
Endel is an app that takes
everything we know about sound,
combines it with technology, and creates
personalized soundscapes to help you focus,
relax, and sleep.Their app was named the Apple
Watch App of the Year in 2020 and they have a
brand new soundscape called Wind Down that
they made in collaboration with James Blake.
The goal of Wind Down is to help you
transition from an active day to a
calmer state, so it’s great just before bed too.
Sound has a direct impact on your physical and
mental wellbeing, and by adapting in
real-time to things like your location,
weather, and heart rate, Endel creates simple,
pleasant sounds that can help to calm your mind.
If you’re interested in trying out Endel, just
be one of the first 100 people to download it
using the link in the description and you
will get a free week of audio experiences!
Thank you to all the people whose
names are on screen right now.
They are our Patreon patrons. We love what we
do at Journey to the Microcosmos, this team
is just delighted to be able to do it, and I am
so glad that other people love it too because
without them we would definitely not be able to
do it, so thank you so much to all of our patrons.
And if you are interested in becoming one, you
can check it out at Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our
master of microscopes, James Weiss,
you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram,
and if you want to see more from us,
there is always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby.